[Music]
hello there hey guys it's been a while
since i've done a facecam video on this
channel hasn't it i think the last time
was actually when i announced i was
coming back and keeping on that trend i
guess i have another announcement
i am taking a break
for a little while at least so here's a
quick little tidbit in like my five or
so years of doing youtube full-time i've
never taken a break from this channel
for more than about a week i know it
might not seem like it to you guys but
even if there's a month of slow uploads
i would constantly be working on
something whether that be scripting
another video planning out my next few
videos watching anime i needed to do
another video so for once i just wanted
to officially announce that i'm going to
take a bit of time off from this channel
in my mind it's probably going to be
about a month or so now i know there's
going to be one swami comment out there
that's going to be like
one month that's just a normal gig
upload schedule right i know i could
have taken like a month or two off and a
lot of you probably wouldn't have even
noticed i've had months before without
uploads hell i've had several months
before without uploads shout out to the
ogs to remember that period but i knew
if i didn't say something there would be
this pressure in the back of my mind to
come back and sit down and work whether
that be scripting a bit editing a bit
more a video or just catching up to this
non-existent work schedule i had set for
myself because even if i had a very busy
schedule before any spare time i had i
would be pressured to just sit down and
do a little bit of work here and there
so i'm making this video for you as much
as i'm making it for me gant for the
next month you do not have to work on
any giggup videos i've got no videos in
the backlog to upload no videos in the
works nothing prepared i've got nothing
so when will my next video be i don't
know however long it takes me to make a
new video from scratch when i come back
for my break so don't expect a massive
project to drop because i've taken a bit
of time off that's all i'm trying to say
but guards why now why are you taking
this break well if you haven't been
following my life from this channel
alone then i am getting married yes it
has been a long time coming but i am
getting married to the very lovely
sydney aka sidsnap the queen of
degeneracy god that is not a sentence i
ever thought i'd say in my life in
regards to getting married but uh here
we are funny little facts but we should
have already been married like two years
ago but unfortunately due to covert back
then our wedding got pushed back several
times and here we are two years later
and it's finally [ __ ] happening oh my
god for the longest time it didn't even
feel like it was happening like i forgot
for like a year and a half that i was
actually getting married because uh i
didn't know if it was gonna be cancelled
or delayed another time so now it kind
of feels surreal and oh my god i can't
tell you how difficult it's been to try
to plan a marriage in the uk while still
living in japan while also having a work
schedule on like three different
channels now but you know what now that
all the final preparations are almost
done now that i see people flying in
from all different sides of the globe
just for this one event it's like it's a
feeling i can't describe i'm so excited
i am so hyped and it just makes me feel
like everything's gonna be worth it
which of course it is so you know i
wanted to set aside some time for not
only the event itself but just hanging
out with the friends and family some of
whom i haven't seen since pre-pandemic
and just enjoying married life you know
and before you ask hey giggup when's the
marriage video coming out
i don't know if we're gonna release one
all right look if we feel like releasing
one we're gonna release one if we don't
we don't the day hasn't happened yet so
i don't know if there's anything i want
to keep private to myself or if there's
anything i choose to share publicly i
hope you guys can respect that side of
my own privacy but at the very least
you'll probably see a bunch of pictures
and uh probably a bunch of stories from
trash taste not only that though but i'm
also going to be attending a bunch of
conventions this year by the time this
gets released i probably would have
already attended mcm london future garde
i hope you had a great weekend that
weekend but aside from that i'm also
going to be attending ax aka anime expo
from the 1st of july to the 4th of july
me and the boys are all gonna be there
we're gonna have panels we're gonna have
signings and we have some more special
things planned as well so look out for
that it's going to be an amazing weekend
in la if you're able to join but wait
there's more i'm also going to be
attending smash corn from the 16th to
17th of july in sydney australia with
sydney that's right i'm gonna be in
sydney with sydney
god i can't wait for the amount of times
that line's gonna be set that weekend
it's gonna be my very first time in
australia so i'm so so excited i've
wanted to go to australia for the
longest time in my life so for any
chance you're in australia or sydney
come say hi and hopefully maybe we can
share a pint together i don't know
that's what aussies like to do right so
yeah all in all just a very busy time
for me coming up that doesn't mean
you're not going to see my face at all
though of course you can catch the
weekly episodes of trash taste if you
want to see my face and i may still be
doing the odd stream here and there you
can catch my twitch at
twitch.tv on my second channel guards
not grant gant if you want to see some
of the stream highlights but if i do
decide to do something just so you know
it's not going to be planned it's if i
have a spare few hours and most
importantly it's if i actually feel like
it it's not gonna be work gone it's not
gonna be work don't [ __ ] work i swear
to god yeah i think that's everything i
had to say today i know it's rare for me
to actually do an update video i guess
this is an update video i just hope i
come out these next few months in one
piece so without further ado i've been
gigguk and i'll see you all next time
bye
[Music]